ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément moins de paris
mais toujours loin de ce qu'il y leur
vie ressemble assez peu à ce qu'on voit
à la télé ils ont le sentiment d'être
des français de seconde zone comme s'ils
étaient invisibles ces français ne
veulent plus se taire ils ont des choses
à dire la france oubliée c'est une
rencontre avec ces citoyens qui ne se
résignent pas à la fatalité la france
oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit
jamais
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans l'oise et
plus particulièrement à tracy le mont
[Musique]
je
bonjour moi c'est alfredo ouais alors tu
vas te présenter alfred août
alfredo fial trésorier de l'association
tracé compagnie à tracy-le-mont un pur
monde est beau et puis quoi d'autre
ah oui si mon âge peut-être 64 ans a
fait 26 ans qu'on s'occupe de cette
salle et qu'on fait on va dire la fête
quand même on essaye ouais c'est pas
facile en ce moment ça c'est même très
dur à vue quand même pas le droit d'être
là donc aujourd'hui ici c'est une salle
de concert c'est un lieu de
rassemblement culturel
ouais c'est en fait on fait pas
seulement les concerts il ya aussi des
représentations théâtrales ont fait
beaucoup d'expositions bâle a en fait on
en boit une
et puis on a des ateliers théâtre des
ateliers arts plastiques
on va faire le tour du propriétaire ou
du locataire ou de l'occupant des lieux
ne sais pas comment il faut dire val
locataire veut on est locataire
ici c'est un terrain vague donc on
l'avait aulas fait d'abord le muret
apprend la fait venir un bulldozer qui
nous a appelés tout ça c'est la pratique
sortent du coup c'est une ancienne
brasserie way un des usines qu'est-ce
qui se sont arrêtées quand alors là le
dernier atelier je crois que ces 77
on faisait de la brosse alors
essentiellement de la brosse de luxe qui
partait aux états unis pour les pourquoi
pour les habits à pour tous pour
contenant la havane ont alors là avec
des poils des vrais poils d'animaux web
bien sûr l'hérault du port du de tuya
c'est incroyable tu vois quand je suis
arrivé c'est ce que je me suis dit
pourquoi ils ont mis un balai brosse
donc c'est le totem rien voilà pourquoi
voilà c'est quand même l'âme du village
donc on essaie de faire revivre ce il y
avait 2000 ouvriers atrassi qui avait 17
café il y avait et d'ailleurs quand je
dis 2000 ouvriers on a on n'a pas
retrouvé la population qui avait a bondi
hier avant 14 18
on est toujours donc un peu plus d'un
siècle après on a toujours besoin de
population ici qu'il avait à l'époque
quoi haut à une jeune fille qui
s'activent là j'ai du mal à voir de loin
et donc là vous faites du jardinage
depuis depuis le printemps qu'est-ce que
vous planter là là je désherbe mais on à
planter des choux de bruxelles
et puis des salades et puis on avait
planté des tomates au 11 juin et qui ont
donné à ces tomates vertes pour faire de
la confiture c'est important pour vous
de tricher en barriques
ben oui parce que parce que c'est ça
fait partie de mon histoire familiale
l'histoire du village ça concernait
toutes les familles soit le travail est
la brosserie soit ils étaient chartier
et transporter les les bois qui arrivait
en gare de ribécourt soit aisée des
cartonniers donc tout le monde
travaillait pour la boucherie
merci nicolas va vous laisser vaquer à
vos occupations qu'elle regarde tu
portes aujourd'hui sur cette société
qu'est ce que cette un site c'est que
c'est l'argent roi tout fait pour avoir
du fric du fric du fric on sait pas à
quoi ça sert mais il faut faire du fric
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on ne voit
là une étape financiers je rappelle
quand même quand j'étais bon y avait
quand même des patrons l'industrie y
avait des gentilles team était débile
mais puis qui risque est aujourd'hui à
peu ça existe opus
même les banques on leur demande après
il faut le rembourser 4 point de presse
où ils ont vu ça donc voilà on est dans
ce boom là c'est aussi pour ça que me
suis mis à mon compte
parce que tu sais si tu as du boulot
c'est pour toi aussi t'as pas de boulot
c'est de ta faute
ça sera pas la faute de x2 aide ce sera
toi
et voilà c'est un petit salaire je suis
même pas au smic mais ce moque c'est pas
nous c'est pas le but
le buteur vosges et puis la maison j'ai
de quoi assumer ma vie tous les jours
suis pas gourmand j'ai des freins
si corinne g va pas au resto va pas au
ciné c'est un choix de vie je préfère
mettre mon énergie dans la salle je fais
pas ça pour les gens ça d'abord parce
que ça me plaît à moi et voilà
et parce que je sens bien qu'il ya une
demande ce sont bien qu'ils ont besoin
de ça et même là aujourd'hui
la région le département tout ça ils ont
aussi besoin qu'on soit là parce que
voilà on investit le rural là ils disent
tout en vert le le le milieu rural il
est abandonné par will abandonné b donc
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont besoin de nous
nous on fait parce qu'on a plaisir à le
faire
tu votes encore oui je vote de vote
doivent être beaucoup boulot mais je
vote parce que c'est le geste
républicain par excellence alors même
s'il y avait on imagine entier plus
d'état on va dire un
on est dans un monde où il n'y a plus
d'état il faut quand même que les gens
se réglisse et qui décident de ce qu'ils
veulent faire et donc partiellement de
pour voter c'est ce qu'on va faire on va
rentrer dans ce beau lieu tuquoi de
l'émission ont fini la séquence par une
photo on va faire la photo à l'intérieur
dans ce lieu où tu passe vraiment pas
mal de temps ouais ben tu vois alfredo
regarde vois que tu as un beau chapeau
australiens tu vas te mettre derrière le
rideau l'arrêt ouais tu vas juste
apparaître un petit peu tu va tendre le
bras
voilà comme les parfaits j'ai le droit
de dire quelque chose
peuvent-ils ce que tu veux à votre bon
coeur messieurs dames pour les artistes
[Musique]